foreign
[Music]
who cares what he calls himself
foreign
[Music]
this music video is really throwing me
off it's not throwing me off because I I
grew up in the age when music videos had
their Advent and we we in the 80s things
were crazy Madonna was singing Like a
Prayer in front of burning crosses and
you know Boy George was dressed like a
dress wearing full makeup and you know
hair bands we had men with like long
hair and black lipstick and and
everything was crazy so this to me the
humping is throwing me off this to me is
nothing what's bothering the only thing
that bothers me about this is that Sam
Smith has you know made statements that
you know are social political and it's
like oh just stop it already like just
do your crazy artsy video be whoever you
are you're an artist it's not a bad song
it's all right so far yeah like like
just this is just super artsy and it's
creative and quite frankly the set is
gorgeous I want to go there too
[Music]
free shows and music videos
this February we're partnering up with a
Navy SEAL friend of ours Tom Shea host a
21 day virtual event that you guys can
join with us Tom is going to teach you
how to listen to your mind in a new way
and how to control it so that you can
have the discipline you need to build
the life you want whether it's working
out your relationships your money your
spiritual growth this is a 21 day
virtual event where you get to learn how
to kill the excuses in your head and you
get to learn some discipline and those
are things that's how successful people
get successful best part is when you
come in through us you get a discount on
the enrollment so use code Sunny fast50
to get 50 off the event you will not
regret it you will be a changed person
at the end of it do not miss this so if
you're interested becoming a reformed
human an absolute animal go to
tomshay.com and use Sunny fast50 for 50
off of this program
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what's the word I'm using this is Haram
this is Haram this is Haram this is what
kids the kids are watching when they're
looking up their new favorite Sam Smith
song looking for somebody for somebody
to take home looking for somebody to
take home
[Music]
sneako's banned but you can drink
Aladdin
oh my God
[Music]
is this talking about orgies
I don't think so okay
[Music]
and open and free
happiness you know really life
fulfillment people love people who are
you know like this for years and years
end up being really satisfied when they
hit 40. I'm so glad so glad I'm red
pilled so glad I'm not into this [__]
[Music]
what do you think about Andrew Tate I
guess I wonder what they would say
[Music]
some of the costumes
I wonder what the budget was
the grown man
it's all right it's fine I mean maybe I
just am desensitized by the 80s it's
just not my cup of tea it's not my cup
of tea I don't like this I don't like
the gay swallowing Aladdin and
um you know gay hump gay dude humping
each other that's not my thing if you're
gay and you don't like watching I mean I
don't even want this [__] like just the
straight people doing this all over the
place yeah this is nothing about gayness
like that I don't think I don't think
I'm not saying it's not about what I'm
saying I'm saying for me I don't I don't
I just like I don't have that big of a
problem with it I have a problem with
the society that I've never seen
normalize this I'm not comparing you I'm
just saying I have a problem with this
idea that wants to normalize like
hypersexuality because I can just see
how bad it's gone and how bad it's going
but it was a creative video what are you
gonna do he's got a market he's doing
well thanks for watching
um I'm sorry and watch it if you got
through it first and last time all right
thank you for watching make sure to like
subscribe follow me on Instagram at
sunnyfast some cuff boys kind of thing
reacting to the music videos but all
right thanks and I'll see you later
[Music]